welcome to the heavy spoiler show
i'm your host definition aka number two
face
and today's just been an amazing day if
you're a dc
fan in addition to the batman logo being
dropped today we've just had a report
from vanity fair that says ben affleck
will be returning alongside michael
keaton as batman in the upcoming flash
movie
throughout this video we're just going
to be breaking down all of the news but
there might be some spoilers here so if
you don't anything ruined then i highly
recommend that you turn off now
don't forget to subscribe to the channel
for videos like this every day and
please drop a thumbs up if you're as
excited as we are
without the way thank you for clicking
this now let's get into the breakdown
okay so according to the report the
flash movie which is planned to release
in summer 2022
will feature the fast-moving speedster
barry allen breaking the bonds of
physics to crash into various parallel
dimensions
vanity fair did a great write-up on this
that i'll leave in the description below
and they go into massive amounts of
detail about what's going to be
happening
when discussing the project andy
muscetti who's going to be directing it
said that ben affleck's batman has a
dichotomy that's very strong and
masculine
but at the same time he's very
vulnerable he knows how to deliver from
the inside out
and that vulnerability it adds so much
more to the character
and provides it with a lot of contrast
he's going to be playing a very
emotional part of the movie
and in my thinking this is going to be
his final farewell and a great send-off
for the guy who i think completely
nailed the role now we do know that
michael keaton is also going to be
featuring in it
and i think that this is going to be a
passing of the torch in case you haven't
read flashpoint
basically the flash travels back in time
and saves his mother and then returns to
the present to find a slightly altered
dc eu
i think at the start of the movie ben
affleck's batman is gonna be there
flash will then travel through time and
he'll return to the present to see
michael keaton there and be like
what the hell man when did you get so
old now we do know that michael keaton
will be playing
a sort of nick fury role in the entire
dc eu
and that he'll be leading the charge
going forward this opens the door for
batman beyond
uh basically the entire bat family and
yeah i think this is a brilliant
brilliant way to not only send off ben
affleck
but also introduce the way that things
are going to go when discussing this
musketee said the interaction
relationship between barry and affleck's
wayne
will bring an emotional level that we
haven't seen before
it's barry's movie it's barry's story
but their characters are more related
than we think
they both lost their mothers to murder
and that's one of the emotional vessels
of the movie
that's where affleck's batman kicks in
he further went on to say i'm glad to be
collaborating with someone who's been on
both sides of the camera too
so we do know that there's going to be a
lot of grid added to this
now obviously as i'm sure you can tell
i'm massively massively hyped for this
there were rumors that ben affleck was
going to be returning for a batman tv
show which i never really bought into
that much
but it's great to see that he's gonna be
back so he can get this proper send off
as i'm sure you know this role really
took a toll on affleck's life
and it's just great that he's getting
this final farewell i kind of have to
admit that i was wrong as i didn't think
that he would come back
at all so it's great to see him back you
know to do this final film
if it is indeed the final who knows he
might do even more
i've never been more happier to be wrong
though and yeah it's got me very very
hyped for what we're gonna see in the
film
now obviously i'd love to hear your
thoughts on the news and if you missed
our last video and which we break down
the batman logo
the suicide squad justice league trailer
and things that we've heard about other
films
then definitely check it out after this
don't forget that we're giving away a
free copy of marvel's avengers on any
console of your choice
and all you have to do to begin with the
chance of winning is like the video
leave a comment
subscribe to the channel and yeah just
stay tuned for that giveaway
if you want to support us so that videos
like this can get made then please click
the join button below
you can also come chat us on our discord
server linked in the description or
heavy spoilers on twitter
if not thanks for making it until the
end of the video i've been definition
you've been the best and i'll see you
next time take care
peace
you